[Music]
Well, good afternoon, good friends. Uh
we're glad that you decided to join us
for our program. I'd like to know uh as
probably many of you know this is a
question and answer program uh where you
send us your questions and we do
everything possible to answer those
questions by doing research. So uh we
want to begin our program uh with a word
of prayer. I have with me here uh James
Rafferty who is an associate speaker for
Secrets Unsealed. And uh so I'm going to
ask him to have a word of prayer and
then we'll jump right into our
questions. Sounds good. Let's pray.
Father in heaven, we just want to pause
in your presence, ask for the direction
of your Holy Spirit as we navigate your
word in answer to these questions. And
we just pray that all of the answers
will come right from the word of God and
that they will relieve uh the
questioners, the hearts, and the minds
of those who've asked these uh important
questions. We pray that others who maybe
have not asked these questions or
viewing now will also be blessed. And we
ask these things in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. I also want to remind you if there
are individuals who have never seen this
program before where you can send us
your questions. Uh you'll see it on the
screen. It's tvsumtv.org.
TV
tvsumtv.org. So send us your questions.
We'll be glad to do the research and do
everything possible to answer. So uh we
have uh two questions left over from
last time, Pastor Raerty. And so we want
to take a look at the first one and I'll
go ahead and read it and then maybe you
can um take take off with it. Sure. Uh
it says, "Good day. I have read Pastor
Boore's notes on Daniel 9 and it says
that the theocracy ended after the
70week prophecy. And then I heard
another preacher saying that Patriarchs
and Prophets at the very end of its
index says that it ended after
Zedekiah." quoting Ezekiel
21:25-27. Is there a conflict here or
did I misunderstand something? Yeah,
that's a really good question. You know,
uh the theocracy. So, according to
Daniel chapter 9, uh there was a
prophecy that was given, a time prophecy
that was given. Uh and 70 weeks of that
prophecy was allotted to the Jewish
nation. And that 70we portion uh began
in 457 BC. And it extended all the way
through to the New Testament times and
ended in AD.34.
And the last week of that prophecy, we
know we can pinpoint it. In fact, I've
done a little research on this uh and
wrote a little interesting book on this.
You can actually from the New Testament,
you can actually pinpoint the baptism of
Christ, Messiah, the anointing of
Messiah, and you can go
backwards
483 years, not 490, but 483 years
because he was baptized in AD27, and you
can get to the date 457 BC, right? One
week after he was baptized, we see the
end of that 70 weeks. And we see that
capstone in a sense by the stoning of
Steven. And what's really interesting
about the Stony of Steven is Stephen, a
deacon who's filled with the Holy Ghost,
begins to rehearse the history of the
entire Jewish nation. And we see this
happen often in prophecy when a nation
is coming to its close, its end. We saw
we see it happen in Daniel chapter 5,
for example, when Daniel rehearses the
history of Babylon just before it falls.
Mhm. And so this kind of in a sense puts
a capstone on the end of that 70we
prophecy and really brings an end to
this theocracy, this Jewish nation being
under God for all of these years, no
matter whether they went up or down into
apostasy and back up again. All of it
was leading down to the end of this 2300
day prophecy or the 70we portion of the
2300 day prophecy. Maybe we can look at
a little bit of the chronology because
the the question is is there a
discrepancy between believing that the
theocracy ended with the stoning of
Steven or whether it ended in the times
of King Zedekiah. Okay. And uh and so
maybe I can just go over a little bit of
the chronology. Um before the Babylonian
captivity, the Shikina was in the
temple. Okay, we know that for sure.
Mhm. But according to Ezekiel 8, there
were tremendous abominations that were
being committed in the city. And
therefore in chapter 9, you have the
sealing of those who are signed and
crying because of the abominations.
Right? Then you go to chapters 10 and 11
and it speaks about the departure of the
Shikina. It goes above the city and it
uh kind of lingers on the Mount of
Olives before going to heaven. In other
words, Shikina abandoned the city. Isn't
that interesting? After the captivity,
um the uh temple was rebuilt, but the
shikina never entered the temple.
And so some people say, well, that's the
theocracy ended there. But it didn't
because Hegi has a prophecy where he
says that the glory of the second temple
would be greater than the first temple.
I'm way ahead of you're already. I know
you're way, but it helps to get the
chronology. But I've never heard this
before. Yeah. To know when. Yes. When it
is that the theocracy ends, it can't end
it during the time of Zedekiah. Because
the Shikina was still going to come to
the temple. Exactly. But of course, you
know that the Shikina came to the
temple. What does that mean? The Shika
came to the temple in the form of Jesus
Christ, right? He taught in the temple
court. Yes. Right. Yes. And he did the
same thing that you just described
happening in Ezekiel chapter 10. You
know, he came to the court to the temple
at the very end of his ministry. And as
he got ready to leave the temple and he
said, you know, your temple is left unto
you desolate. He he waited there at the
mount of olives. I mean, the whole thing
is just repeated. Yeah. He he lingered
on the Mount of Olives and gave the
prophecy of Matthew chapter 24. Yes. But
but even then, even though Jesus says,
"Your house is left unto you desolate."
The theocracy did not end there. Right.
Because in Matthew chapter 23, if we can
go there just for a moment, Matthew
chapter 23, mercy still lingers for
three and a half years. Yes. Um these
these are the woes on the scribes and
Pharisees, right? And uh it says there
in chapter uh 23 of Luke, actually
Matthew and uh verse 34, therefore
indeed I send you prophets, wise men,
and scribes. In other words, say I'm
going to send you Yes. uh prophets, wise
men, and scribes. Some of them you will
kill and cru and crucify, and some of
them you will scourge in your synagogues
and persecute from city to city. That's
Paul. That on you may come all the
righteous blood shed on the earth from
the blood of righteous Abel to the blood
of Zechariah, son of Bariah, whom you
murdered between the temple and the
altar. Assurely I say to you, all these
things will come upon this generation.
This Y. And so Jesus is saying even
though the temple has been left
desolate, I'm still going to give you an
additional three and a half years. Yes.
But of course after three and a half
years, they closed the door of probation
for the Jewish theocracy. And that's
when the gospel went to the Gentiles.
Yeah. It was scattered abroad. And the
interesting thing is that the book of
Acts is organized according to Acts
chapter 1 7 and 8. the gospel was going
to Jerusalem, Judea, to Samaria, and to
the ends of the earth. Well, if you look
at Acts 1-6, you have the gospel going
to Judea, to Jerusalem and Judea. You
look at Acts chapter 7, that's the
stoning of Steven. Okay? Chapter 8, the
gospel is going to Samaria. Okay? And in
chapter nine, you have the experience of
Paul on the Saul on the way to Damascus.
Oh, on the way to Dasc. Gotcha. Okay.
And so now he is converted and he be
becomes the the individual that takes
the gospel to the ends of the earth.
Wow. I know. I never saw that before.
And so and so the book is structured
there at the very beginning in those
verses you have the structure of the
book. And maybe we can just read uh Acts
chapter um let's see Acts chapter 13.
So the very outline that Jesus gave to
them becomes the structure of the the
book of Acts of the of the early church.
Right. I didn't realize that. Uh so
notice Acts 13 if you want to read
verses 46 and 47. Um the context is that
Paul and Barnabas are visiting. Okay.
And uh their message is being rejected
by the Jews. And so notice what the
Apostle Paul has to say. Then Paul and
Barnabas verse 46 of Acts 13 waxed bold
and said, "It was necessary that the
word of God should first have been
spoken to you. But seeing you put it far
from you, and judge yourselves unworthy
of everlasting life, lo, we turn to the
Gentiles. For he hath for so has the
Lord commanded us, saying, I have set
thee to be a light of the Gentiles, that
thou shouldest be for salvation unto the
ends of the earth. Interesting. Ends of
the earth. The same expression that is
used in Matthew chapter 28. Yeah. That
you're to preach the gospel to the ends
of the earth. The same expression that's
used in Acts chapter 1 seven and eight.
Wow.
So, so um good stuff. What is the answer
to this question? The answer to this
question is that the theocracy did not
officially end until the year 34. Yes.
It did not end in the times of King
Hezekiah. Yep. And the the Shikina
returned to the temple in the person of
Jesus Christ, right? And lingered there
as he closed out his ministry. lingered
there with the promise that the prophets
and and uh others would come, the
apostles would come and give them
another three and a half years of mercy
of of teaching and preaching. It's
amazing how uh passages that are
separated by hundreds of years
harmonized. Yes. Like hand and glove.
And that's the interesting thing about
these questions. These questions bring
up uh contradictions. You know, there's
they seem to be contradictions, seeming
contradictions, but then it all
harmonizes and all comes together.
Right. I love that. I love that. Good.
Well, I think we've answered this
question. So, now let's go to the next
question. Uh, this one is a very
interesting one. It's based on uh that
special resurrection that took place
when Jesus resurrected. I'll just read
the question. I have a specific question
regarding the special group of saints
who were resurrected together with Jesus
Christ. Of course, in itself, this was
an extremely extraordin extraordinary
event which must have attracted a lot of
attention and awe from many people who
witnessed all this. Therefore, it is to
me unexplainable why there is hardly any
reports on this event. Number one, the
Bible hardly reports about it. Only the
Gospel of Matthew mentions it, but
nowhere do we find further details. I I
beg to differ with that particular
point. Number two, I also cannot find
any extra biblical sources of that time
like the Jewish historian Josephus who
reports about it. Only in the writings
of Ellen White do we find some important
details relating to this group, who they
were, how large was the group, in what
kind of body they resurrected. If such a
thing would happen in our time, it would
be world news for weeks or even months.
How can it be that this was not widely
reported during the days of Christ's
resurrection, especially that the word
of God hardly pays attention to it? So,
that's the long question. That's the
long question. And there's a lot of
points here that we can make. I'm going
to go backwards and just start from the
back. How can it be that this was not
widely reported during the days after
Christ's resurrection? It probably was.
It probably was widely reported during
the days of Christ's resurrection.
That's how it got into the Bible. The
only way that it could have gotten into
the Bible was was something that was
wellknown. The Bible writers wrote much
later than the early church uh these
events happened. And so for them to go
back and recount some of these events,
it had to have been something that was
widely reported. Another thing I think
is really important too is John closes
out his book in John chapter 21 and he
says something I think that's really
interesting. Let's just look at these
verses real quickly. John chap 21 and I
want us to look at verses 24 and 25 of
John chapter 21. This is the disciple
which testifies of these things and
wrote these things and knows that his
testimonies we know that his testimony
is true and there are also many other
things which Jesus did the which if they
should be written everyone I suppose
that even the world itself could not
contain the books that should be
written. Amen. Yeah. So it's called
hyperbole but uh very true.
we call it today we call it TMI too much
information it's like okay okay okay
okay enough uh so I think you know
there's a lot of things that Jesus did a
lot of miracles a lot of wonders and I
say that because you know definitely the
resurrection of this group of this group
of people that went and witnessed was
connected with Christ it was connected
with his resurrection and in fact it
Matthew's account says that you know
after his resurrection uh but they
aren't necessarily recorded Can you
imagine the kind of things that weren't
recorded? Never mind, you know, what was
recorded. But you mentioned something
earlier and I want us to go back to
that. You said something about how he
said, uh, but nowhere do we find further
details. And you said, I beg to differ
with that. I beg to differ because, um,
we have the additional light that is
provided by the spirit of prophecy.
Okay. Uh, let's read the passage first
where this is described. Some people are
probably wondering what are they talking
about. M so let's go to Matthew chapter
27 okay and verses
51-53 and if you want to read that James
uh Matthew 27
51-53 all where we find a description of
this resurrection all right Matthew
27:51 and behold the veil of the temple
was rent in twain from top to the bottom
and the earth did quake and the rocks
rent and the graves were opened and many
bodies of the saints which slept arose
that was verse 52 53 and came out of the
graves after his resurrection and went
into the holy city and appeared unto
many. You know, I checked several Bible
commentaries about these verses. They're
really fuzzy. Everyone has his own
speculation about who was in this group.
Okay? Uh but the passage, you know,
doesn't tell us who they were, right?
How many there were, right? when they
lived,
how they died, and whether they
resurrected with their mortal body or
with their glorified body. Okay. But
Ellen White has some very interesting
details that I would like to share.
Okay. The first one is in Desire of Ages
786 where she explained as Christ arose,
he brought from the grave a multitude of
captives. Now we know how many. Okay, a
multitude. Now, where else do we find
that word
captives? He took from the grave a
multitude of captives. You know,
Ephesians 4:8. Yeah, maybe we better
read that verse. Ephesians 4 talking
about the ascension of Christ. Yeah. And
and and and responding to this thing,
but nowhere do we find further details.
So that's why I say I beg to differ that
that the Bible doesn't have anything
more to say about it. The Bible does
have more to say about it. So Ephesians,
of course, that's based on Psalm 68.
Ephesians chapter 4 and verse 8 talks
about captives. Ephesians 4:8
says, "Wherefore he saith, when he
ascended up on high, he led captivity
captive and gave gifts unto men." That's
talking about Pentecost. That's when he
gave gifts to men. Yes. But when he
ascended on high, but before that, he
ascended on high and he let captivity
captive. Okay. So, Ellen White has a
basis for saying that they were
captives. Of course, they were captives
in the grave. They were dead. So, she
continues, uh, as Christ arose, he
brought forth from the grave a multitude
of captives. Now, we know the number.
Okay. The earthquake at his death had
rent open their graves. And when he
arose, they came forth with him.
They were, now she's going to identify
who they were. They were those who had
been co- lababorers with God
and who at the cost of their lives had
borne testimony to the truth. So they're
martyrs. They were martyrs. Yes, they
were martyrs. And that expression very
interesting. They had borne testimony to
the truth.
That is the identical expression that
Jesus uses of John the Baptist in John
chapter 5 verse 31-33. Okay. It says
that he bore witness to the truth. Okay.
Yes. Why is that important? Well,
because Ellen White has some additional
information that's very helpful about
when these martyrs died. Okay. Uh in
um in early writings, page 184, she
wrote, "Those favored risen saints came
forth glorified." Now, we know that they
weren't mortal. They were glorified.
They were chosen and holy ones of every
age from
creation down even to the days of
Christ. That's going all the way back to
to the beginning. All the way back to
the beginning till the times of Christ.
Till the times of Christ. So from Okay.
And they were martyrs. And they were
martyrs. So they were martyrs witness
till the times of Christ. And they
witness to the truth. I'm thinking of
Abel right now. But yeah, keep going.
Well, yeah.
Absolutely. Thus, while the Jewish
leaders were seeking to conceal the fact
of Christ's resurrection, God chose to
bring up a company from their graves to
testify that Jesus had risen and declare
his glory. So let me just summarize uh
the details. They were captives in the
grave. They were saints. Matthew chapter
24 says that they were not a handful.
They were a multitude. Okay? For they
came forth from their graves when Jesus
resurrected.
They received their glorified bodies.
They were people that lived from
creation to the days of Christ. Okay?
They were martyrs who bore testimony to
the truth. Mhm. They went into the city
and testified about the resurrection of
Christ. Okay. Now, uh who would be the
martyr who died from the times of
creation? I think you mentioned it.
Abel. It would be Abel. Yes. Now, who
would be the martyr? The only martyr
that we know of that died in the time
when Christ was on this earth. John the
Baptist. John the Baptist. John the
Baptist. And the identical expression
that Ellen White uses, he bore testimony
to the truth is used of John the
Baptist. Wow. This reminds me of Moses
and how he ended up, you know, going
being laid to rest, but shortly after
that, he was taken to heaven. Something
very, very similar. And John the
Baptist, it sounds like, went through a
similar. So John the Baptist was there.
He just took a short siesta
because he died during the first year of
Christ's ministry, right? and and so you
know we're talking two and a half years
later this is happening and so uh you
know we can't prove that he came forth
but he's the only martyr that the Bible
mentions uh taking place in the times of
Christ. This is interesting because you
know that a lot of times we think oh I
wouldn't want to be martyed. I wouldn't
want to be martyed. Um so Daniel
probably isn't there but Isaiah would be
there right? Uh I would think so. Yeah.
And I think about this, I'm thinking
Jesus selected martyrs. He selected
people who had really suffered for him
and he brought them forth with himself.
I that's just special. That's just cool.
I love that. And you know, it's
interesting. Uh one one further detail
is that in Matthew
uh which we were at a little bit little
Matthew 23. Oh, Matthew 23. Okay. The
woes on the scribes and Pharisees. Yeah.
Uh this the very verses that I read
before.
Um, notice what what Jesus says uh in
verse 34. Therefore indeed I send you
prophets, wise men, and scribes. Some of
them you will kill, crucify, and some of
them you will scourge in your synagogues
and persecute from cities to city that
on you may come all the righteous blood
shed on the earth from the blood of
righteous Abel. Oh yeah, there's a first
martyr. Yes. and the blood of Zechariah
son of Jereiah which would be uh the
Zechariah who wrote the book of
Zechariah. Okay, because Zechariah 1
verses 1 and two say that that Zechariah
was the son of Barakiah. Okay, who is
the last martyr mentioned in the Old
Testament? So Jesus is is saying the
martyrs from creation all the way till
the times of the prophet Zechariah. But
Ellite says that it includes martyrs
that lived in the times of Christ. And
there's only one, John the Baptist. John
the Baptist. So we got at least those
three. At least those three. I like
that. So and and and you know, can you
imagine? Can you just imagine John the
Baptist uh if he was among those who
resurrected in heaven during the the
early persecutions under the Roman
emperors and also those who perished at
the hands of the papacy
Ellen White says that his faithfulness
and his martyrdom inspired all of those
martyrs that died under the Roman
emperors and under the papacy. Yes. Can
you imagine John the Baptist looking
down and saying, "Wow, it was really
worthwhile to die as a martyr. Look at
everybody who's being saved by my
testimony and feeling forsaken of God
and feeling left alone in a dungeon."
And Jesus doesn't come to visit and he
they can look at him. That is profound.
That is profound. He probably won more
souls after his death than during his
life. Yep. Yep. And we look look at this
too. I think it's important for us to
connect Ephesians with the Old
Testament. I've got a reference here. I
don't know if if you're familiar with
it. I'm sure you are, but I've got a
reference here in Ephesians to Isa to
Psalm 68. Yes. Are you familiar with
that? Psalm 68. Absolutely. Um, and I've
got verse 18. That's where it begins in
Psalm 68. Because again, you know, that
the point was made. There's not a lot of
information here, but I think there is.
I think that, you know, when we look at
this um in Matthew 27, as you mentioned
earlier, where it talks about the saints
being resurrected, and then in Ephesians
4 and now in Psalm 68, I think it's
really talking about the same thing
here. Absolutely. Let's start here. In
fact, in fact, Ephesians 4:8 is quoting
Psalm 68. Okay, there you go. So, um I'm
going to say at least verse 18. Thou
hast ascended on high. Uhhuh. and hast
led captivity captive. That's what we
read in Ephesians chapter 4. Okay. Thou
hast received gifts from men. Yay. For
the rebellious also that the Lord God
might dwell among them. Yeah. So I I
like this phrase here for the rebellious
also because I believe that when the
early church was gifted with the Holy
Spirit, one of the reasons that they
were gifted with the Holy Spirit was to
witness to the rebellious. Yes. And one
of the people that witnessed to the
rebellious that was filled with the Holy
Spirit, which we talked about in an
earlier question was uh the deacon
Steven. And you know when he was stoned
to death, filled with the Holy Spirit,
he said, "Lay not the sin of their
charge." And there was a young man
standing there that had all the coats of
all of those religious leaders that were
stoning Steven. And his name was Saul.
Mhm. And because he was gifted with the
Holy Ghost and gave this testimony of
the gospel, Saul could not shake the
conviction that Stephen was speaking.
That's right. For God. That's right. And
he ended up being converted. Yeah. You
know, and when it mentions the gifts
given to men, those are the gifts of the
Holy Spirit. And what was the purpose of
the gifts of the Holy Spirit? It was so
that they could use those gifts to
witness Yes. to the resurrection of
Christ according to Peter's sermon in
Acts chapter 2 that he was sitting at
the right hand of God and he was
receiving clients who would come
repentant confessing their sins and
claiming the righteousness of Christ.
Yes. So it says he ascended on high he
gave gifts to men. That's the ascension
of Christ and the outpouring of the Holy
Spirit and the gifts of the spirit on
the day of Pentecost. And that's huge.
That's huge in. So, is there anything
else here in Isaiah 6? I mean, in Psalm
68. Well, I think that uh I think there
probably is. Okay. Uh you know, you go
to verses 24 and 25. Okay. It speaks
about a procession and they're singing
with the procession. All right. Uh you
know, Psalm 24, if you read Desire of
Ages was sung while Jesus was ascending
to heaven in the procession to heaven.
Okay. Open up your gates. The king of
glory will come. Is that what this is?
King of glory. So it says in verse 24,
they have seen your procession, oh God,
the procession of my God, my king, into
the sanctuary.
The singers went before, the players on
instrument follow instruments followed
after. Among them were the maidens
playing timberals. So there's this great
celebration as the procession is moving
into the sanctuary. Wow. Bless ye God in
the congregation, even the Lord from the
fountain of Israel. And of course, the
beauty of this is when you connect it
with Psalm 24 and the last three pages
of Desire of Ages where Ellen White
describes the ascension of Christ and
the songs that were being sung. It's
simply amazing. And you know, it gives
you goosebumps and it makes you desire
to actually have been there when this
happened. I like verses 19 and 22.
Blessed be the Lord which daily loads us
with benefits. Even the Lord even the
God of our salvation. He that is our
God. Verse 20 is the God of our
salvation. And unto God God the Lord
belong the issues. That's what the King
James says. Or escapes from death.
That's the New King James. Escapes from
death. Y. So again, in the context of
this, all the glory is going to God
because he's giving escape. He's leading
captivity captive. He's giving all of
these captivities to the grave. He's
giving them freedom. He's giving them
escape from death. So, the Psalms are
also messianic.
Absolutely. You know, at Jones said
once, and I took him up on this, he
said, "Read the Psalms as though they're
prophesying of Jesus." Yeah. And you get
a whole new perspective. Absolutely.
Well, you get a whole new perspective by
seeing Christ in the entirety of the Old
Testament. I mean, many Christians say,
"Ah, yeah, you're Old Testament
Christians. You know, we're New
Testament Christians. We're grace, your
law. But really, you cannot understand
the New Testament without the Old. It's
impossible. Well, time is just about up.
Uh, and we've only answered two
questions. We have two or three more.
We'll do it next time. Thank you so much
for joining us. Uh, we we appreciate you
tuning in 4:30 on Tuesdays. And may God
bless you and keep you. And we hope to
see you the next time on this program.
I'd like to know. Amen.
[Music]